[Musik]
wie es im beruf ist die tellerwäscher
karriere ich möglich also ich bin mit 14
news zur schule geflogen und nimmer
hätte geglaubt dass ich zu untersuchen
ist aber geschafft weil man alles
richtig machten und herrschaft und immer
am ball blieb ist die ganz weit offen
mit 38 jahren hat daniel um alles
erreicht was man in seinem metier
erreichen kann
sein restaurant in new york gehört zu
den besten der welt
warum will er das kochen trotzdem stets
neu erfinden und warum interessiert es
ihn noch immer nicht wie viele
überstunden erarbeitet davon handelt
dieser film
[Musik]
das tägliche ritual der chef de cuisine
jeden gang des abendmahls sein geschmack
sind erkennt feinste abweichungen von
der perfektion
sind das genug
sollte ein fluten zu jedem biss seien
sieben oder neun fotos muss und ich will
die tomate mehr schmecken
das braucht ein wenig soll roms new york
arrest rausholt bei allen bewertungen
die höchstnote der legendäre gibt
mischler etwa zeichnet ihn mit dem
maximum von drei sternen aus dass wo
mich trieb mich immer wo auf der ganze
welt geschafft verteilen so sehr
talentiert sind und mit denen jeder tag
das ist wahnsinn getrieben der aargauer
ist chef über 180 angestellte 70 von
ihnen sind köche also etwa zwölf jahren
nach amerika kaum sprache kein wort
englisch der erste satz den er lernte um
ihn seinen köchen einzutrichtern make
nice macht es schön
[Musik]
frühmorgens in new yorker central park
sind sie gestresst morgen habe ich zwei
oder vier stunden später ganz leichte
kost
ja es ist wahnsinnig könnte stunde
länger schlafen
für diesen film stellte daniel um nur
eine bedingung sein privatleben bleibe
privat bekommt ist er hat drei töchter
und ist geschieden
ist eine spärliche freizeit verbringt er
mit sport heute kämpft er sich durch ein
intervalltraining um ist ehrgeizig er
will dieses jahr am new york marathon
seine bestzeit von 2 stunden 50
verbessern
da haben sie auftrag will sich merck st
da würde ich mir wirklich ganz
vorsichtig velofahrer harnik merkt dem
smart cover vastic sie sind und gegen
eine verstellte gaal trainiert ich bin
ein guter weg sie aber nicht voll stabil
und beim kochen geht eingenommen und
prüferinnen ich nicht das ist sein
ehrgeiz er will platz eins in der
weltrangliste der 50 besten restaurants
doch zuerst wartet die nächste meile auf
ihn
[Musik]
als der 14-jährige daniel engines nach
barth von der schule flog seine zukunft
nicht gerade vielversprechend aus erst
in der kochlehre blühte er auf und
machte den besten lehrabschluss der
ganzen schweiz
heute gilt der 38-jährige als
kulinarisches er bespricht mit seinen
engsten mitarbeitern die fotos für sein
viertes kochbuch haben wir irgendwo noch
zweifel finden wir das hier wirklich gut
war das foto
gefällt dir nicht stimmt was können wir
besser machen
wir müssen etwas besser machen lasst uns
nochmals daran arbeiten
sein kampfgeist vergänglichkeit will
eigentlich ihre kunst schon immer wieder
bücher für ihre gäste ja genau oder wie
es geht nicht es bleibt die idee leute
ihre ideen erinnerung was kasse hand
aber es ist wie es ist wenn wir das
nicht ins buch durch die 20 jahren im
verein ist sicher wichtig dass man die
bücher oder für mich ist wichtig dass
man die bürger machen um sagt kochen sei
nicht kunst sondern handwerk und doch
wirken seine kreationen wie kunstwerke
[Musik]
geschmack ist wichtig denn präsentation
ist zwar wichtig oder vor allem auf dem
niveau das gehört alles dazu es ist ja
und das ist eigentlich schwierigsten
versuchen im moment versuchen das
gericht so extrem reduziert werden als
er wie zum beispiel ist das tomate
kriegt da es ist wirklich so reduziert
da das gesetz automatisch aber es ist
viel mehr dahinter
und das ist befehl nicht richtig so es
wird immer schwieriger und wenn nur
wenig sagt larisch sind hat ja keiner
krumm kein platz mit zu meinen fehler
machen
[Musik]
das restaurant liegt mitten in manhattan
wenige minuten entfernt kaufte er seine
zutaten ein auf dem markt am juni in
square
[Musik]
um kocht ausschließlich mit saisonalen
produkten die farmerin hinterland von
new york anbauen
miniatur habe ich im inland dienst
geschickt und ich habe irgendwie immer
freundlich und irgendwo ohne dass sie
das haus deswegen mehrfach sei ja ist
wunderschön nur vier mal die hände
privater luxus produkt ist gesiegt haben
wir auch einzelläufer trüffel aber für
mich luxus produkt ein rötlich oder boni
und ich glaube die gäste langsam
versteht
er sorgte für aufsehen als er einzelne
gemüse zu hauptgängen seines luxus
restaurants machte zb karotten der
aargauer ist überzeugt dass sein freund
alex das beste wurzelgemüse der welt
anbaut
um hat ein kochbuch mit porträts seiner
lieferanten veröffentlicht es ist eine
liebeserklärung an ein new york das kaum
jemand kennt ein fruchtbares im land auf
dem fahrer wie alex ihr gemüse anbauen
[Musik]
oft stehen spitzenköche im ruf
cholerische des boten zu sein darum geht
mit seinen angestellten auffallend
herzlich um
der ton ist freundlich die stimmung
gelöst
ich glaube es ist wichtig dass mir ali
kur mit den handlungsrahmen würden wir
verbringen so viel stunde zu nehmen sind
14 50 stunden pro tag morgens immer
merkt sie und ist nach dem 12 ist im
nebenzimmer und und es nur in familien
verbringen 40 40
das ist nicht so freundschaftlich die
hand auf den tisch
sie sind freunde familie zum thema sowie
der umgang noch locker sein durch die
regeln sind klar
alle chefs an diesem tisch müssen den
perfektionismus und den ehrgeiz des
chefs bedingungslos teilen um räumt ein
es sei nicht immer einfach unter ihm zu
arbeiten
ich meine jeder des mini e der alle
springer jeden tag nicht mehr als gut
mit ihnen ist sehr freundlich ich so
liebe die leute wirklich vorwärts epe
durch verschafft aber es geht da mal ein
punkt wo ich nehme so marco damit wir
dadurch irgendwie mit dem kopf neu
miteinander stich und dann funktioniert
es nehmen oder es funktioniert nun mal
so landwehr wirklich bereit ist alles
für das recht hans g die sitzung findet
in der mittagspause stadt wehrführung
kocht trend nicht zwischen arbeit und
freizeit wenn sie überhaupt sind für
feinde einigen das klassische zum selber
nicht viel aber es ist nicht wichtig
normalerweis die einfache sache
inspirieren eigentlich bin ich ziemlich
dürfte merck er ist einfach das und ich
bin gerade in frankreich sind charakters
kam ganz einfach aber super wollt was
ich will mir inspirierend weil die
andere fine dining restaurant
früher arbeitete daniel huber als
angestellter des restaurantbesitzers
doch er wollte mehr
er wollte sein eigener chef sein vor
vier jahren gelang es ihm das dilemma
diesen park zusammen mit einem
geschäftspartner zu kaufen
warum henry schütze der name nett von
ihnen das vertrauen der großen
franken
der krach
einmal in der woche testet um neue
gerichte zwei seiner köche arbeiten
ausschließlich für den bereich forschung
und entwicklung
unter seiner leitung erfinden sie völlig
neue gerichte um sagt kreativität auf
abruf sei eine der größten
herausforderungen in der küche
das schmeckt großartig findest du genau
aber ich mag die streusel darunter nicht
da gehört etwas anderes wenn vielleicht
kartoffel streifen süßen und normale
kartoffeln und nudeln nur so eine idee
vielleicht nicht verkaufen vielleicht
etwas frisches es ist noch zu spielen
ein weiterer vorschlag aus der
entwicklungs küche zwiebelringe gefüllt
mit kartoffelstock und blut putin
die soße passt nicht
trüffel wirken gut passen oder
vielleicht blut musste verzogen mit
apfelmus und streusel und obendrauf denn
die gefüllten zwiebelringe
obendrauf eine schicht apfelmus dann die
straßen
und dann zuoberst die zwiebelringe
es gehe darum dass man der kreative
prozess immer im lauf verhängt auf und
ich damit meine ich die wirklich jedem
nach einiger marken restaurant wäre das
ein stolzer haupt
ja da ist sehr wichtig dass sie sehen
wenn meine handschrift aussteller konnte
ist wichtig das braucht viel dass man
alles gott wahnsinnig viel arbeit ins
gericht wurden am schluss so für eine
menge holz
[Musik]
einige blogs um ihr leben möchten park
entfernt hat daniel um ein weiteres
restaurant und hotel eröffnet das nomad
[Musik]
mittlerweile führt er ein gastro
unternehmen mit über 500 mitarbeitern
und das ist erst der anfang
in den nächsten monaten wird der drei
weitere restaurants eröffnen unter
anderem eines in los angeles eine
karriere wie im hollywood film zwar
nicht vom tellerwäscher aber vom
schulversager zum multimillionär
zurück im leben mehr ist ein paar im
speisesaal laufen die letzten
vorbereitungen für den abend zerriss die
kellner bedienen jeden abend 100 gäste
die 225 dollar für das degustationsmenü
bezahlen
nein
traditionell herrscht in restaurants
eine strikte trennung zwischen tischen
mannschaft und servicepersonal warum
gehören alle zu einem großen team das
ein gemeinsames ziel verfolgt den gast
glücklich und zufrieden zu machen
reservationen sie nur 28 tage im voraus
möglich
das restaurant jeweils innert weniger
minuten ausgebucht
und natürlich verbietet es die
diskretion über all die berühmten
menschen zu reden die hier tauchen
thunfisch auberginen tomaten
die speisekarte ist lediglich eine liste
von produkten aus der die gäste jene
auswählen auf die sie am meisten lust
haben
dann setzt eine armada von köchen
hausrezepte um er sagt demuth und
präzision seien die wichtigsten
eigenschaften eines kochs ich beginnen
coach
wie wählen trainer und lies vor die
wichtigste sache
wir brauchen ist dass moral extrem
häufig und das ist die moral ist hoch
obwohl die löhne tief sind die jungen
köche sind motiviert weil sie bei home
möglichst viel lernen wollen
wer sich in der küche des landes im park
bewährt dem stehen in der gastronomie
alle türen offen solange er bereit ist
auf sehr vieles im leben zu verzichten
ich kann hier das tor für mich sagen
damals reporter ich sage ja wissenschaft
für die auf 15 stimmen pro tag ich habe
mir eine stunde pro tag nun erzählt und
sich für mehr ruhe und slava das finde
ich
gäste haben einen küchenstuhl gebucht
und den berühmten koch persönlich zu
treffen um schlüpft für einige minuten
in die rolle des stars
dann stellt das sich wieder wie alle
anderen hinter den herd
ich glaube das ist gerecht
[Musik]